this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular characters come in to have a
drink sometimes they share stories and
even secrets for as we all know what the
bartender hears is confidential isn't it
some cinder tending bar but in watts
want the big guys himself Simon Belmont
and I'll gotta tell you this guy's been
on so many adventures so many quests but
even convict sauced it so make him a
drink and I'll say boy you look more
tired than usual Isis all that's all
these missions they've been sending me
on you know and all significant
emissions nice as well after I kill
Dracula you know for the 12th time
eventually I started to get the
reputation of a vampire hunter don't sit
well that kinda makes sense I mean you
did kill pretty much the king of the
vampires and they said that's exactly
the problem finished on top too early I
mean after Dracula what's next
nothing and also look I don't know I
keep hearing those vampires all around a
man sort of a big phrase they said yeah
well that's the other part of the
problem you see the first job I got was
to kill this one vampire who I think was
a reject from say bonnibel or something
I think he's one of those metrosexuals
cuz they used some sort of skin cream
that just made it Sparkle all over I'm
thinkin oh you're talking about but what
Emma said I thought he was very popular
and unpopular at the same time and he
said that's exactly yet you see for a
while they want to keep him around
because he was supplying so many funny
jokes and so much humor on the internet
a whole new genre internet memes was
invented because of this guy but now
they want me to kill him because nobody
will stop making the jokes it's not the
vampire Harlem shake it was good for two
seconds and then after that everybody
was sick of it and I said okay fell
enough well what'd you do did you stab
them through the hall with a steak
places no I found a much more effective
way of destroying him that's a tower
beside destroyed his career do you ever
think he's gonna get another acting gig
that's gonna have any dignity to it
after that I don't think so well done
and I'll so okay so you did something
good for the Internet what's wrong with
that yes as well but jobs just haven't
been as inspiring as they used to be I
mean everybody hates vampires now so
they're hiring me to kill as many
vampires
as possible that's it really like who I
said well there was this purple one who
hand obsession with math somebody put a
hit out on him and so I had to do my
duty and it was awkward he said every
single time he stabbed him through the
heart he will count how many times he
did it but even stranger thing he said
is that the skeleton of this creature
didn't even match his outsides it's like
a five digit it thing but I'm getting
off track I asked him who else did you
go after he said there was this other
strange one who barely had an obsession
with chalk that's a chunk I guess he got
that name by advertising a serial mouse
nothing but sugar coated chalk I thought
about that for a second I want yeah that
makes sense but I'll ask him Izu who put
the hit out on that one
blue guy and a pink guy and apparently
they have an affiliation with this green
guy I try not to ask to make questions
especially with people who look as
strange as they do and I'll said that's
pretty cool you're up there with some of
the great Vampire Slayer's then they
said yeah but my dad did my job a little
too good now so what do you mean that he
said vampires just aren't around anymore
both the bad and the creatures they're
just both dying I'm not gonna lie says I
went through some very tough times I
dyed my hair red I stopped wearing fur
coats it was a very confusing time not
so much age what did you do
they said luckily I found vampire
Slayer's Anonymous and I couldn't
believe how many vampire Slayer's were
going through the exact same thing I was
there was this van heckling fellow some
black guy named Blaine some really
eccentric chicle fluffy I don't know
what her backstory was but we all came
together and said we had a good run but
times change and it's time to evolve to
something else
I said well good for you man so what are
you doing with your time now they said
I'm an exercise trainer
I said really they said yes his mother
is a whip people the shape and of course
I haven't
laughs at the power it's a light pun but
what don't you do it says no no
literally I would people in the shape
you'd be surprised what a good motivator
that is if they're not running fast
enough or lifting those weights a good
latch to the back will really fix that
up and I'll said well that sounds
disturbingly frightening but I'm curious
have you ever thought about going back
to vampire slang
I said well sometimes I have when the
night is young and the moon is full and
I'll see a bat fly by which naturally I
kill with the dagger but that's probably
just mean to me I'll do miss being a
vampire slayer' and I told them I said
well you ever think about hunting
zombies
I said think that that is a whip doesn't
do very well against zombies that's it
well want to just upgrade to a shotgun
Lisa what's a shotgun after I told him
there was just a pup of Simon Belmont
that used to be there and nothing
learned after that I don't know what
it's gonna do with the information I'll
give him exactly about shotguns all the
can hope is that he puts it to good use
it doesn't work into its exercise form
because Guk Gault
the people that go there I think they
suffered enough almost as bad as the
Twilight jokes you see almost strange
things as a bottom does heel ostrich
things at the pixel palace so also your
model strange things as a bartender the
pixel palace and that ain't no my
sweater it